sees the wind moving in a particular
direction especially with this election
and he's like okay how do we get ahead
of it how do we put our sales in a way
where we could still win while the whole
system kind of collapses onto itself so
I I I agree with you on on that one
particular Point yes he's trying to kind
of protect himself with this poll but
but I don't think it's even the poll I
think it's even bigger than this if you
look at his contracts with the defense
industry with the US military with the
Pentagon when it comes to starlink when
it comes to providing Ukraine and Israel
satellite technology that are used for
defensive and offensive capabilities
those capabilities are at his disposal
to use and Implement as he wants that to
me in my opinion is why he's going to be
kind of protected here and if it wasn't
for those kind of larger government
contracts and the larger kind of game
that he plays with a lot of the bigger
kind of um players here I think he would
have been gone I think he would have
been destroyed a long time ago and I
think this really does play a central
role in in a lot of this